oh la la la la chaire pongistes cher
badistes ou pas ouais c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle lé joueur de ping pong et
de badminton de des sports les plus
populaires en chine environ 100 millions
de licenciés pour le tennis de table
alors que le badminton est la discipline
la plus pratiquée en asie mais depuis
quelques années l'empiré du milieu veut
faire du foot un véritable empire
objectif que le ballon rond représente
20% du pib chinois en 2025 et en 2026 la
fédération internationale de rugby
estime que la chine sera première en
nombre de licenciés dans le monde de
l'ovalie
sans oublier les jeux olympiques de
pékin en 2008 et en 2022 alors la chine
nouvelle superpuissance du sport on en
parle après le générique
[Musique]
bienvenue sur arte france pour un nouvel
épisode de l'autre match alors que la
première journée de la phase de poules
de la ligue des champions asiatique
commence on parle de l'asie mais plus
particulièrement de la chine sur le
plateau de l'autre match et on pose
cette question quid de la chine au
niveau du sport nouvelle superpuissance
on en parle avec nos invités rené
lobello ancien entraîneur de liaoning
club chinois justement vous avez été
également l'adjoint de francis gillot du
côté de shanghai
et puis avoue côté emmanuel dupuy
président de l'ipic seul institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
spécialiste des relations
internationales que vous enseignez en
chine avec la géopolitique vous
enseigner ces disciplines du côté de
ningbo et de hangzou merci messieurs
bonjour merci d'être sur ce plateau de
l'autre match pour parler donc de la
chine est ce que la chine et la nouvelle
superpuissance du sport on a posé cette
question aux internautes sur rt france
sur les réseaux sociaux sur plus de deux
mille six cent trente personnes
interrogées voici le résultat
32% des personnes pour ce que oui 68%
pensent que non
rené lobello votre avis pour l'instant
ils sont ils sont deuxièmes sont
peut-être pas loin des états unis et je
pense que dans les années à venir
ça va être un rival important pour être
pour domino pour mondiale quand vous
êtes deuxièmes on parle des jeux
olympiques au tableau des médailles
absolument votre avis alors oui j'aurai
une réponse que c'est complémentaire à
ce que j'ai lu mon collègue ça dépend de
la date à laquelle la question est posée
pour l'instant la chine fait face à un
certain nombre d'aléas et un certain
nombre de difficultés
la chine d'aujourd'hui n'est pas celle
de 2016 au moment où le président jean
ping après trois ans pouvoir faisait du
sport un élément de puissance ou un
élément de soft power comme on dit les
choses ont un petit peu changé la
croissance à l'époque était de 14%
elle est divisée de moitié aujourd'hui
donc il ya aussi un esprit de réalisme
derrière tout ça par contre si la
question est posée à l'horizon 2040 9 le
président jean ping a dit que l'horizon
2050 devait être l'année où la machine
sera la première puissance en terme de
footballistique mais également au niveau
sportif
la question mérite d'être posée et je
pense que il y aura sans doute une
inversion dans le sondage que vous avez
mentionné premièrement parce que la
chine a investi dans un certain nombre
de domaines que ce soit les
infrastructures construction par exemple
mais on y reviendra je le suppose dans
le débat de 60000 stade supplémentaires
d'ici 2022 et donc il ya forcément une
formation des jeunes qui va faire en
sorte que les futures générations dans
tous les domaines que ce que le ping
pong sur le badminton ou que ce soit le
cyclisme les chinois sont très friands
du cyclisme où le football mérite
évidemment peut être de poser la
question d'ici quelques années vous rené
qu'est ce que vous retenez de votre
expérience de vos expériences plutôt en
chine mais je retiens déjà la découverte
d'une mentalité qui est différente de la
nôtre
j'ai rencontré les individus bien éduqué
déjà çà çà çà choc très respectueux
après une adhérente à chaque ils sont
pas bien indiqué en france ça j'ai pas
dit ça il ya ces s'est exacerbée là bas
il ya un sens de la hiérarchie qui est
qui qui pas la même que la nôtre
elle est plus exacerbée en chine et
après au niveau football c'est la
découverte d'une mentalité différente de
la nôtre également à venir des joueurs
qui sont très très disciplinés beaucoup
travailleurs très travailleur et un
volume de travail incroyable sens que
sans que le patron leur demande c'est à
dire je vais prendre un exemple un
joueur qui ne joue pas pendant le match
qui est remplaçant s'ils ne rentrent pas
à la fin du match suivant salle de
musculation il se braque une séance de
musculation
alors que bon en europe on le voit moins
on le voit moins sous couche et très peu
de joie
ce qui m'a marqué vous évidemment c'est
le football mais quand vous étiez en
chine qu'est ce qui vous a marqué par
rapport aux autres sports c'est quoi le
sport numéro 1 en chine c'est le
badminton c'est le tennis de table c'est
le volley ball
alors il ya beaucoup de disciplines qui
sont qui sont prisés en chine je dirais
il ya le tir on n'emporte pas à nous en
france c'est pas trop une discipline
très très reconnu il ya très peu de
licenciés je pense en france
en chine le tir est reconnu c'est
spectaculaire les gens aiment ça surtout
aux jeux olympiques
ensuite le basket parce qu'il ya eu un
joueur qui a été un petit yao ming
voilà qui est parti en nba et il ya le
football bien entendu il ya le volley
ball
ensuite il ya deux choses qu'il faut
prendre en ligne de compte où les gens
sont très intéressés c'est le sport
masculin et le sport féminin
par exemple en football l'équipe
féminine est très suivi en chine c'est
un petit peu ce que j'ai pu remarquer je
pas si vous l'avez vous l'avez aussi
remarqué en chine
voilà c'est ce que je retiens le plus de
mon passage en chine avec des sports qui
le football émergent pour voilà le
phénomène émergent en tous les cas
xi jingping vous en parliez emmanuel
dupuy le président de la chine veut
faire du foot bien véritable empire il
veut que le foot représente 1 % du pib
chinois en 2025 il souhaite
cinquante mille écoles en 2025 il veut
accueillir la coupe du monde 2030 avec
l'ambition de la gagner est ce que c'est
réalisable
écoutez tout est réalisable à la mesure
de l'ambition dévorante de la chine
je crois que les chinois ont cette
différence avec la france de planifier
les choses
d'ailleurs le président jean ping a bien
organisé
structurellement la montée en puissance
de l'affluence du sport dans sa volonté
de se positionner comme une princesse
grandes puissances à l'horizon 2040 9
l'année 2000 49 et symbolique à double
titre c'est la fondation du parti
communiste chinois
et c'est la fondation de la république
populaire de chine c'est aussi l'année
où le prix jean ping souhaite être un
partenaire stratégique ou vise à la
parité stratégique avec les états unis
les experts disent d'ailleurs que ils
dépasseront les états unis avant
certains disent 2030 deux n'a en tout
cas l'objectif que s'est donné le
président jean ping
de plus on encaisse domaine au niveau du
sport au niveau économique industriel
lithaire économique sportif diplomatique
dans tous les domaines la chine veut
être la première puissance en 2040
quel intérêt d'être première au niveau
du sport c'est quoi ces soft power brial
internationale rené lobello voix
je dirais que l'intéressé d'être d'abord
de d'être reconnus d'être reconnu en
tant qu'expert dans tous les domaines du
sport
moi je parle de sport c'est c'est de
mettre d'avoir la sla la suprématie en
sport tout simplement est de faire en
sorte que la chine soit reconnu comme un
grand pays est le premier au cercle des
médailles c'est l'une des ambitions et a
eu les jeux olympiques de pékin en 2008
mais il va y avoir les jeux olympiques
de pékin également en 2022 et ce seront
les jeux olympiques d'hiver c'est pas un
peu paradoxal il ya de la neige
apple il ya de l'allant déjà il ya des
montagnes à pékin alors oui mais les
olympiques ne se tiendront pas à pékin
ils se tiendront dans les montagnes
autour de pékin la chine est un grand
pays et donc elle a la capacité de
montrer que c'est un pays à la fois
centralisée mais évidemment englobant la
toute la population dense dans ce même
effort mais je crois que c'est très
symbolique
je reviens une question vous allez poser
tout al heure grégory sur l'ambition que
ce que s'est donnée le président jean
ping s'est non seulement d'avoir le plus
grand nombre de médailles mais d'avoir
le plus grand nombre de chinois qui
pratiquent le sport c'est ça qui est
important
le sport est obligatoire évidemment
comme dans toutes les nations mais avec
une particularité c'est qu'il veut
rendre le foot ball obligatoire n'est
pas d'ailleurs beaucoup de licenciés il
corrige moi c'est une trompe 140000 du
sancy la peau france je pense que cela
m'a dit oui c'est ça avec 100 millions
de licenciés en tennis de table en tout
cas c'est bien la différence
l'idée de la chine c'est d'être présent
sur des sports qui lui sont un petit peu
étrangère et cette notion d'être une
grande puissance va de pair avec la
volonté d'être une grande puissance
globale comme les autres où on
comparable aux autres c'est pour ça que
la notion de parité stratégique fait
l'objet d'un plan le prince jean ping en
2016 à ses implants 50 points qui du
reste ont été complétés en 2018 avec 18
règles pour que la chine devienne la
première puissance dans le football
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une dimension
financière et fiscale et dimension
symbolique c'est le sport qu'est le plus
regardée dans le monde c'est pour ça que
healy à cet intérêt et puis un autre
intérêt historique
les présidents chinois ont toujours été
très friands de sport le prédécesseur de
jean ping dyson ping était un fanatique
de football et il
rappeler que le football s'inscrirait en
chine dans la durée si les enfants jouer
au football d'où la focalisation vous
l'avez 10 sur les cinquante mille écoles
de formation d'ailleurs il ya la plus
grande école de formation dans le monde
evergrande dont 3000 doit jouer wagner
campus le club acheté par l'oligarque
chinois on peut l'appeler comme ça jack
ma le patron d'alibaba du meuble et j'ai
là aussi je rebondis sur ce que vous
avez dit celui de tous les deux mais
aussi un petit peu comme en russie une
volonté de nationaliser un peu le sport
indirectement en obligeant les grands
patrons des grandes entreprises qui
appartiennent toutes au parti communiste
on a appris il ya peu de temps cuggia
cma appartenait au parti communiste a
investi relance par les dix plus grandes
fortunes chinoises sont tout
propriétaire d'un club de foot en gym
parler de jack ma a justement il a donc
investi je vous propose de regarder ce
que dit jack ma donc le président
d'alibaba au sujet du football chez ali
baba notre stratégie c'est la santé et
le bonheur investir dans le foot c'est
investir dans le bonheur
qu'est ce que vous avez vu concrètement
sur le terrain par rapport aux
investisseurs chinois dans le football
rené lobello déjà moureu à gages à
shanghai chinois s'était greenland qu'a
pris le club donc comme comme disait mon
collègue greenland c'est ça fait aussi
une grande société c'est une société qui
construit des bâtiments des ponts et
elle est dirigée aussi par le parti
communiste
elle appartient au parti et c'est de
mettre en place le professionnalisme
voilà et ça c'est indéniable ensuite a
suivi le club de deva grande où cet
homme a mis beaucoup d'argent dans ce
club a fait venir des entraîneurs comme
lippi cannavaro avec les meilleurs
joueurs
ils sont champions d'asie qu'ils ont
réussi d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de grands joueurs qui qui
viennent en c 1 kg 10 super league csl
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle le
championnat chinois il ya des gervinho
hulk
ce gars car également le brésilien boîte
grands joueurs ats voilà carlos tevez on
voit gervinho juste derrière vous parce
que le championnat chinois appris
beaucoup en très peu de temps et font
tourner la tête 7 millions de dollars
les droits télé de la saison 2014-2015
140 millions de dollars en 2015 2016
comment expliquer en lots bello un tel
essor en si peu de temps
mais comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure le football c'est pratiquement
une des sports les plus connues dans le
monde et la chine ne veut en faire
partie il va être un des meilleurs
elle se donne les moyens elle se trouve
comme vous avez dit tout à l'heure elle
se structure à travers les écoles à
travers les clubs professionnels de la
ligue la ligue professionnelle de
première division à cslc j'ai oublié le
terme et à partir de là il se donne les
moyens
alors ça va mettre du temps comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure ses structures
et ça va prendre du temps mais quand ils
veulent quelque chose les chinois ils
vont y arriver
donc ils vont être champions du monde en
2030 à la longueur du monde en 2003 en
non je ne pense pas je c'est un avis
personnel je ne pense pas qu'ils seront
champions du monde en 2030
déjà s'il arrive je pense que l'étape
avant d'être champion du monde c'est de
participer à une phase finale
trois quatre fois durant ça fait déjà
presque 16 ans entre 12 et 16 ans
participer à une phase finale c'est déjà
une bonne chose et je pense que pour la
gagner il faudra encore plus de temps à
voir de très très bons joueurs et je
pense que dans les années 2050 comme le
plan le prévoit eh bien peut-être que je
miserais un kopeck là dessus messieurs
c'est la pause c'est la mi-temps mais
bougez pas parce qu'il ya l'autre match
revient dans un instant
de retour sur le plateau de l'autre
match pour la seconde période pour
parler du sport en chine rené lobello
ancien entraîneur de club chinois
présents sur ce plateau toujours là aux
côtés d'emmanuel dupuy président de
l'ihh ps qui enseigne du côté de la
chine la géopolitique forcément le sport
c'est de la géopolitique on a aperçu
récemment mesut ozil
un joueur allemand qui évolue à arsenal
être entre guillemets blacklisté du côté
de la chine pour ses propos tenus par
rapport aux ouïgours je vous propose de
regarder le sujet de clément delcourt au
sujet de la chine et la géopolitique du
sport
la chine ne rigole pas avec les sportifs
engagés et les houston rockets en ont
fait les frais octobre dernier le
directeur général de la franchise texane
cubi un tweet en soutien à hong kong
conséquence des retransmissions annuler
des sponsors qui menacent de partir et
un tollé politique en chine et aux états
unis
un peu plus tôt un joueur esport a quant
à lui été suspendu un an de toute
compétition par l'éditeur de jeux vidéo
blizzard lors d'une interview d'après
match il avait appelé à libérer hong
kong
là aussi les réactions politiques
avaient afflué au ce dossier épineux la
situation des ouigours le joueur
allemand d'arsenal n'est utile a
publiquement affiché son soutien à cette
ethnie musulmane ce résultat la
diffusion de certains matches d'arsenal
ont été annulés les commentateurs de
football ne prononce plus son nom à la
télé et il a été supprimée de la version
chinoise d'un célèbre jeu vidéo
emmanuel dupuis vous enseigner la
géopolitique en chine quelle place pour
la géopolitique à travers le sport en
chine
côté le sport fait intégralement partie
de la politique de conquête à travers
l'influent sont nombreuses pas en
anglais on appelle le soft power
c'est d'ailleurs contextualiser dans un
texte qui est celui qu'a prononcé le
président jean ping à l'occasion du 19e
congrès du parti communiste chinois où
il évoque le fait que le sport qui
contribue à la stabilité à la
pacification et au bonheur des chinois
d'ailleurs le thème général c'est
l'élaboration de la société de la
moyenne aisance et je crois que c'est
très important parce que les chinois
veulent non pas dominer le monde
mais combattre les lacunes auxquelles
ils font face est la principale lacune
en tout cas je serai présent c'est la
pauvreté et le fait que la chine ait
réussi à éradiquer l'extrême pauvreté
85% de la population était en dessous du
seuil de du seuil de pauvreté
dans les années 2000 800 millions de
chinois sont sortis de l'extrême
pauvreté
une des façons aussi que la chine a de
conquérir le coeur et les esprits des
chinois c'est de les mettre au sport
et d'ailleurs le président une pile ne
cesse de dire qu'il veut que le sport
soit une valeur chinoise
on ne prenant que le côté positif et non
pas le côté négatif votre reportage
montre bien que tout ce qui peut créer
polémique est évacué et justement au
niveau des polémiques
vous parlez de basket un tout à l'heure
rené lobello on sait que la chine
organisé le mondial de basket à
l'automne dernier en septembre puis a eu
également ce qui s'est passé et ce qui
se passe toujours d'ailleurs du côté de
hong kong et au moment où la nba
reprenait il y a eu un tweet du
du propriétaire de houston en soutien
aux manifestants
anti couverts du manteau à hong kong et
yao ming donc vous parliez tout à
l'heure la super star des houston
rockets d'ailleurs à l'époque s'en est
mêlé justement comment est ce que vous
vous sur place vous avez vécu ce côté
entre sport politique géopolitique
on n'est pas concerné par ça quand on
est bon à prendre dans un club
professionnel
on est un petit peu dans une bulle on
est omnibulé par les séances
d'entraînement aux normes du but les par
les matches on est omni bull et pas les
résultats
seul compte le résultat après le reste
on est protégé de tout on est vraiment
dans le club on dort au club on mange au
club
voilà on est on est 24 heures sur 24
dans le club et on n'est pas en
hermétique à tout ça et comment les
chinois que vous avez entraîné
vive le sport parce qu'ils sont quand
même très nombreux comment est ce qu'ils
font pour pointer les meilleurs il
s'entraîne dur notamment au football
parce qu'ils savent qu'il ya un retard
en fait ça démarre le football là bas ça
a démarré depuis une dizaine d'années
c'est pas vieux
10 15 ans à la limite et encore je
dirais que ça a vraiment démarré à
partir de 2015 ou là il ya eu vraiment
des dispositions prises par rapport au
championnat c'est c'est bien cadré c'est
bien encadré
c'est bien cadré par les clubs
professionnels il ya des structures
d'entraînement il ya tout ce qu'il faut
pour progresser
quand on voit que le championnat
d'angleterre en chine c'est 660 millions
d'euros c'est à dire que c'est le
premier marché à l'export pour la
première league anglaise le fait de ne
plus diffuser des matches du championnat
d'angleterre dans lequel il ya par
exemple les autres choses il est arsenal
derrière ça fait mal au portefeuille des
britanniques non c'est pas seulement au
coq au niveau des britanniques
d'ailleurs les chinois investis dans
machester city
le président jean ping s'est d'ailleurs
rendu du côté de manchester city c'est
le plan photo avec aguero et s'est pris
en photo également avec david cameron à
penser qu'il a investi dans ce club vend
pas beaucoup 13% pour ça c'était quand
même un investissement considérable
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
pas forcément pour le club mais c'est
précisément ce que vous disiez pour la
les écoles de formation parce que parce
qu'on se rende compte que les chinois
utilisent le sport comme et peuvent
utiliser
la prédation avec beaucoup de guillemets
dans un certain nombre de secteurs
industriels
c'est à dire qu'ils veulent avoir en
chine les meilleures structures qui
existent ailleurs
donc ils vont investir dans un certain
nombre de clubs qui sont partis reconnus
pour leur école de formation
pourquoi la chine a investi à loger ce
show ou ou à l'office et nice ne pas
oublier également l'asie milan ac milan
ils ont notamment racheté la semil en
740 millions de dollars 1 fois qu il le
rappeler et là dessus on peut aussi
penser que le sport français
laure est plus accessible parce que ça
coûte moins cher mais pourquoi auxerre
sochaux l'ogcnice et l'olympique
lyonnais 20% des hôpitaux ni parce qu'il
ya les écoles de formation parce qu'il
ya un modèle de formation à la française
vous en êtes l'exemple ils achètent
n'ont pas forcément le club l'image mais
ils achètent la préparation pour les 50
prochains à venir pour les rendre
compétitifs et meilleur c'est vrai pour
le football mais c'est vrai pour plein
d'autres sports
alors il ya quand même quelques écueils
je sais pas si vous l'avez vécu comme ça
le président jean ping appelle à ce
qu'il y ait la construction de 60 mille
nouveaux stades à l'horizon 2022
en oubliant qu'il ya une bulle
immobilière qui touche la chine en
oubliant que beaucoup de promoteurs font
tout pour que les espaces dédiés aux
grands vins structures sportives ne soit
pas aussi grande pour permettre des
investissements immobiliers qui
rapportent davantage
et puis il ya aussi un changement vous
qu'il nous fait que la chine a sans
doute commencé à s'intéresser au
football à partir de 2015 2016
il ya une date ou une autre date c'est
2017 2018 avec une nouvelle politique
sur la corruption et de ce point de vue
il y as sans doute à l'avenir peut-être
moins de chance de voir évoluer des
joueurs internationaux
la chine vient juste de débuter une
règle un salary cap à sanaa deux choses
la classe la taxe 100% luxe c'est à dire
que quand vous atteignez un certain
nombre de 2 à mon temps pour un certain
nombre de transferts vous devez payer le
double pour que cet investissement cet
argent soit investi dans un fonds pour
le développement des futures générations
et puis il ya effectivement une nouvelle
taxe où on va plafonner le salaire par
semaine de kara
49 mille euros par semaine nous ou moins
500 milles par semaine ça veut dire
qu'il y aura plus de gervinho de l'udc
deux oscars de l'avensis à côté de son
côté de la chine parce que les joueurs
vous qui êtes entraîneur de football qui
avait entraîné en chine
les grands joueurs qui viennent en chine
viennent pourquoi ils viennent pour
l'argent simplement où ils viennent pour
aider la future génération chinoise a
gagné la coupe du monde un jour et je
pense qu'il faut être honnête et dire
qu'à un moment donné les joueurs
recrutés en chine
ce ne sont pas des joueurs de 22 ans de
23 ans ce sont des joueurs expérimentés
ce sont surtout des non ce sont surtout
des stars et ils se payent les stars
donc les joueurs ils vont l'avoir pour
l'argent ça c'est clair
et après dans un deuxième temps le fait
qu'ils votent requip existe aussi par
l'encadrement de ces joueurs là parce
que le joueur chinois tout seul il a
besoin il peut pas y arriver je pense
pas qu'il puisse y arriver il a besoin
d'être tirée vers le haut moi ce que
j'ai remarqué en chine je parle de
football
une chose qui m'a énormément marqué
c'est ce manque de créer de créativité
voilà c'est les joueurs ne sont ne sont
pas créatif
ils sont très content j'ai dit tout à
l'heure ils ont un respect de la
hiérarchie un respect des consignes mais
que que j'ai jamais connu ailleurs j'ai
quand même travailler en arabie saudite
travailler dans la en afrique
mais là c'est
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable et
vous leur dites par exemple ce que je
disais à mon collègue tout à l'heure
dite le coach dit aujourd'hui il faut
jouer long un moment donné dans un match
de 90 minutes
il ya des subtilités dans le jeu il faut
comprendre dans le jeu il faut jouer
court il faut jouer vers l'arrière il
faut jouer vers l'avant faut passer sur
les côtés il ya beaucoup de choses à
comprendre dans ce jeu et le chinois va
jouer long et tu dire mais non on
regarde moment donné pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas relancer de derrière c'est un
exemple que je donne et coach on m'avait
dit de jouer long voilà ils sont
respectueux de la consigne et c'est ce
qui me fait dire qu'à un moment donné
ils vont mettre beaucoup plus de temps
que prévu pour arriver au très haut
niveau et les les chinois est ce qu'il
regarde beaucoup le sport à la
télévision parce que une étude qui a été
faite par une filiale de la tns sofres
stipule et qu'il y à plus d'un milliard
à 1,2 cent milliards de téléspectateurs
potentiels en chine
est ce qu'ils regardent vraiment les
matchs de foot il ya plus de deux mille
chaînes de télévision en chine 1,223
milliard de téléspectateurs potentiels
donc c'est un énorme marché est ce que
est ce qu'il ya un match par exemple
entre la chine et les états unis pour
obtenir un alors sachez bien au delà du
foot les je me regarde beaucoup les
sports où il brille je crois que c'est
ça qui est important à avoir l'esprit
les chinois ont évidemment un sentiment
d'appartenance nationale qui est très
100 g alors on peut s'interroger sur les
raisons historiques ou la manière dont
le président en u en abusant ne
l'utilisent mais je crois qu'il ya ce
sentiment d'une recherche
de la suprématie dans tous les domaines
et vous avez mentionné les grandes le
grand rendez vous internationaux et à
une stratégie chinoise qui est
d'ailleurs à peu près équivalente à
celle qu'on peut trouver à l'onu les
chinois estiment que jusqu'à présent ils
n'ont pas été suffisamment reconnus pour
leur capacité d'organisation de grands
événements internationaux
d'où la fierté d'accueillir pour la
deuxième fois la coupe asiatique des
nations à l'horizon 2023
ou le fait admis à 2023
ou le fait ça a été d'ailleurs vécu
comme une victoire diplomatique
d'obtenir l'organisation en 2021 de la
coupe du monde des clubs de sport des
clubs de football donc avec là aussi une
dimension financière puisque la chine au
aurait promis 50 milliards et les jeux
d'hiver en 2022 et les jeux d'hiver en
2022 et les jeux olympiques précédents
en 2008 donc il ya ce sentiment
un petit peu comme on l'a retrouvé dans
le système multilatéral de d'estimer que
la chine en tout cas c'est comme ça que
président évoque le fait d'être
davantage présents dans ces grands
rendez vous internationaux qui sont des
rendez-vous géopolitique parce que vous
montrez que vous pouvez organiser un
certain nombre d'événements vous montrer
que votre population est derrière le
champion et donc les filières sportives
derrière et puis bien évidemment le fait
que le sport est très regardée en chine
tout simplement parce que c'est une
façon aussi de contrôler la population
il à 2000 chaîne certes mais il ya
beaucoup de chaînes qui indirectement
ramène au parti communiste chinois à
lézignan ce que je peux rajouter c'est
que dans mon domaine dans le football
tous les joueurs chez doit comme tout
jeu il y avait des gros matches à la
télé mais la nuit regarder les
manchester les manchester united et
manchester city tous les grands d'europe
il était regardée quoi céder ici donc il
regardait il apprenait même moi je
discutais avec mes joueurs et
les joueurs chinois tu vous disais mais
ce qui fait lui comment il le fait
pourquoi il le fait à quel moment il le
fait il
non seulement ils regardent le match
parce que pour eux c'est le football de
très haut niveau mais derrière ça il ya
un apprentissage
il cherche à comprendre et à reproduire
aussi à léran les gestes à
l'entraînement et à s'améliorer et je
trouve que moi j'ai jamais vu les
joueurs autant de joueurs français ont
regardé les grands matchs comme les
joueurs chinois il savait tout il
connaissait tous du football européen
quoi je parle des joueurs que je
côtoyais c'est la fin de cette émission
consacrée donc à la chine à la puissance
sportive de la chine qui est donc en
train d'éclore sur de nombreux sports
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur sur un
autre plateau de l'autre match vous
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle émission un autre
thème d'ici là vous pouvez revivre cette
émission spéciale chine sur arte france
points à tv en podcast est en replay
bail
[Musique]